bonsoir namur je dois vous faire rêver
donc nous allons voyager dans le système
solaire même peut-être au-delà du
système solaire nous allons essayer de
répondre à la question
les planètes et les lunes du système
solaire sont elles habitable pour
répondre à cette question bien sûr on va
se baser sur des observations sur de la
recherche de la technologie de la
robotique des missions spatiales
on envoie des robots à la surface de
mars
comme par exemple mars heinz laboratory
qu'on voit sur cette image un petit
laboratoire qui va observer la surface
de mars qui est aussi grand qu'une
petite voiture et qui a atterri et qui
est toujours en train de rouler à la
surface de mars
à l'heure actuelle mais avant tout
définissons l'habitabilité qu'est ce que
j'entends par l'habitabilité mais assez
l'ensemble des conditions nécessaires et
suffisantes pour qu'une forme de vie
puisse y exister même si elle n'existe
pas donc la seule forme de vie que nous
connaissions c'est évidemment la faune
la flore les humains sommes tous à sa
besoin de dos d'eau liquide
bien sûr d'énergie et de nutriments sur
terre en plus nous nous avons une
atmosphère nous avons une lune qui
stabilisent notre orientation nous avons
de la tectonique des plaques des
continents qui descendent dans le
manteau de la terre qui remonte parler
les rythmes médio océanique et nous
avons un cycle de l'eau un cycle du
carbone
nous avons un champ magnétique qui nous
protège comme un bouclier des rayons des
rayons du cosmique et du vent solaire en
provenance du soleil alors de l'eau
l'eau liquide
c'est quand même important pour pour la
vie un des trois éléments importants
donc aux énergies
et lequel était le troisième nutriments
les nutriments se soudent c'est ce qu'on
trouve dans les roches tout nous nous
mangeons bien sûr mais les toutous
toutes les formes de vie ont besoin de
nutriments l'énergie l'énergie nous nous
avons l'énergie du soleil reste l'eau
l'eau comment trouver de l'eau à la
surface d'une planète bien pour avoir de
l'eau il faut comprendre ce diagramme de
phase de l'eau l'eau à l'état de glace
solide l'eau à l'état liquide et l'eau à
l'état de vapeur pour la vie on a besoin
de liquide à une pression de une
atmosphère à peu près l'atmosphère de la
terre
on sait que l'eau on à la température et
la pression ici dans ce diagramme de
phase on sait que l'eau passe de l'état
de glace à l'état de liquide à zéro
degré et de l'état liquide à l'état de
vapeur à 100 degrés dans les gammes de
température et de pression qui règne à
la surface de la terre on a donc de
l'eau liquide à la surface de la terre
qu'en est il des autres planètes alors
des planètes comme mars
c'est ma planète préférez vous allez
voir c'est le number one pour
l'habitabilité après la terre alors mars
elle a actuellement des températures
entre -150 degrés et plus 20 degrés et
une pression environ 1 100e de la
pression terrestre à peu près 7000 part
à ces pressions là on a vraiment très
très rarement de l'eau liquide à la
surface de mars
vraiment dans des conditions d'extrême
température penser en plein été haha
à midi alors là on a vraiment la
possibilité d'avoir un tout petit peu
d'eau liquide et encore il vaut mieux
avoir du sel dans l'eau pour descendre
le 7 pourra pas avoir cette possibilité
alors ça c'est pour mars qu'en est il
des autres planètes vénus vénus et mars
est plus loin du soleil un mais on puis
on a la terre puis plus proche du soleil
en à vénus venus comme il pu prouver les
plus proche du soleil plus chaudes et la
une une atmosphère d'environ 90 2 fois
l'atmosphère de la terre une une canette
de soda est écrasé à la surface de vénus
donc c'est vraiment une pression énorme
on a à cause de cette atmosphère un
effet de serre énorme
et cet effet de serre nous donne des
températures au delà de 4 150 degrés en
permanence donc la surface de vénus
comme l'indiquent la la diapositive ici
on a des températures extrêmement chaude
et pas d'eau liquide
qu'en est-il de mercure on est là encore
plus proche du soleil mercure n'a pas
d'atmosphère donc mercure à une nuit
extrêmement froides et un jour
extrêmement chaud on est dans des gammes
de températures le moins 150 degrés est
et plus 400 degrés donc de nouveau pas
d'eau liquide à la surface de mercure
si je récapitule j'ai donc une planète
vénus qui est trop chaude inhabitable
une planète mercure trop chaudes ni trop
froides inhabitable reste ma chouchoute
mars
alors cette planète je laime bien parce
que parce que je les tue dit c'est
vraiment la planète qui sur laquelle je
passe le plus de temps
et en fait les sondes spatiales qui sont
actuellement en orbite autour de mars
nous ramène
des images de plus en plus détaillée est
splendide d'ailleurs vous pouvez surfer
sur le web vous verrez c'est vraiment
splendide et que voit-on à la surface de
mars on voit c'est énorme balafre qu'on
appelle valles marineris valles
marineris et on voit également des
systèmes de deux vallées de rivière de
deltas de rivières des marques d'eau à
la surface de mars
mais pas d'où on ne voit pas tout en
fait ma recette une planète très
intéressante parce que il n'ya pas de
tectonique des plaques
ça veut dire que les la surface de mars
n'est pas rejet nérée comme à la surface
de la terre
donc je peux lire toute l'histoire de
mars à sa surface
et qu'est ce que je vois dans l'histoire
de mars je vois que dans son passé entre
4.6 milliards d'années et 4 milliards
d'années
il y avait de l'eau à la surface de mars
énormément d'eau à la surface de mars
des flux d'eau à la surface de mars
revenons à notre diagramme de phase de
l'eau pour avoir de l'eau liquide donc
la vie à la surface de mars assez mars
maintenant à l'heure actuelle pour qu'on
ait de l'eau liquide il faut monter un
petit peu dans les pressions donc il
faut que dans le passé de mars on est
une atmosphère à ce moment là on peut
avoir deux loups liquide que nous
indique donc nos observations c'est que
dans le passé de mars bien nous avions
une atmosphère et cette atmosphère
à l'heure actuelle à 10 par quasi
disparu il reste sept mini bar de co2
alors donc mars à étaient habitables
comment est ce que une planète qui a été
habitable un certain moment est devenue
maintenant quasi inhabitable et bien
tout ça c'est lié à l'évolution de la
planète elle-même et pas seulement de
son atmosphère aussi de son intérieur
son intérieur des gaz
on a du volcanisme on a du dégazage de
co2 et sa forme une atmosphère
évidemment on a un champ magnétique au
tout début de l'histoire de mars et on
peut le voir dans les roches à la
surface de mars les très anciennes roche
à la surface de mars entre 4 points 6
milliard d'années et 4 milliard d'années
ont imprégné un champ magnétique
c'est un champ magnétique est rémanent
passé fossilisé il y avait un champ
magnétique entre 4.6 milliards d'années
et 4 milliards d'années dont vraiment
tout début de l'histoire de mars
ce champ magnétique joue un rôle de
bouclier contre le vent thermique et
donc protège l'atmosphère sans ce
bouclier thermique évidemment
l'atmosphère c'est rod et on et mars
peut perdre son atmosphère
donc il est intéressant d'avoir un champ
magnétique que nous avons sur terre pour
nous protéger de l'érosion du vent
solaire
on a eu dans toute l'histoire des
planètes des impacts des impacts de
météorites qui ont apporté des volatiles
mais aussi fait échapper une partie de
l'atmosphère
on se pose encore et c'est une recherche
très actuel des questions sur
l'évolution de la biosphère de mars
et là je vous ai donné un grand nombre
de deux d'éléments qui permettent de
répondre à cette question
on est toujours en train de travailler
sur cette planète
mais revenons sur terre et je pense que
je vous ai montré que les planètes du
style de la terre on appelle ça les
planètes telluriques
ces planètes à l'heure actuelle ne sont
pas habitables et donc nous sommes
vraiment bien sur terre et ça c'est un
message que je peux vous faire passer
on a vraiment une chance de dingue alors
petite parenthèse donc on continue notre
voyage dans le système solaire
on est allé vers mercure vénus la terre
mars puis on à la ceinture des
astéroïdes carnon puis derrière cette
ceinture d'astéroïdes
on a des planètes qu'on appelle les
planètes géantes jupiter saturne
par exemple ces planètes autour de ces
planètes quand on observe ce qui se
passe autour de ces planètes on voit un
grand nombre de lune et ça c'est une
petite parenthèse que je voudrais faire
parce que dans notre système solaire
sélune sont vraiment des potentiels pour
l'habitabilité
pourquoi parce que par exemple là vous
avez en haut à droite l'image de la lune
europe lunes de jupiter et voyez cette
lune elle est couverte de glace et en
dessous de ces croûte de glace
eh bien on a un océan un océan liquide
plus on pénètre à l'intérieur d'une
planète où à l'intérieur d'une lune plus
il fait chaud
donc même s'il fait très froid dans ces
mondes la très très loin du soleil
à l'intérieur de ces mondes de glace la
glace fond et on a un océan en dessous
de la croûte de glace d'europe on a un
océan en dessous de la croûte de glace
de ganymède il ya un océan en dessous de
la croûte de glace de titan il ya un
océan donc tous ces océans
s'ils sont en contact avec le manteau
les fameux nutriments on a mentionné
tout à l'heure s'ils sont en contact
avec le manteau bien il ya la
possibilité d'avoir de la vie de
l'énergie on en a là il ya les marées il
ya le soleil etc
il ya de l'énergie on a de l'eau liquide
et on a des nutriments
si l'océan est en contact avec le
manteau dans ses lunes cependant
certaines de celles une ondée j'irai des
sandwichs de deux d'océan et de glace à
l'intérieur de deux élus non on trouve
vraiment des sandwichs
ce sont des modèles pour l'instant on
n'est pas encore allé voir à l'intérieur
de cellules et donc on pourrait avoir
soit des océans en contact avec le
manteau et donc de la vie soit des
océans coincé entre des couches de glace
on ferme la parenthèse on va quitter
maintenant le système solaire et on
clique le système solaire mais mais mais
je voudrais quand même vous leur
représenté dans dans l'ensemble des
possibilités des différents systèmes
solaires donc notre système solaire
c'est un ensemble de planètes qui
tournent autour du soleil
le soleil c'est le gros point jaune sur
la slide il a une certaine masse les
mets une certaine énergie et donc la
terre et dans une zone où l'énergie est
tel que on a une température avec notre
atmosphère bien sûr une température qui
nous permet d'avoir de l'eau liquide
c'est ce qu'on appelle la zone
d'habitabilité
ça c'est pour le soleil cette zone
d'habitabilité elle est au tour de la
terre mars et mercure sont et mars et
vénus pardon sont juste un peu en dehors
de cette zone d'habitabilité
mais il n'ya pas que notre soleil et les
planètes de notre système solaire il ya
d'autres galaxies et même dans notre
propre galaxie il ya d'autres étoiles
avec d'autres systèmes de planète et ses
étoiles et sont soit de la dimension du
soleil soit plus petit soit plus grande
si elles sont plus petites elles
émettent moins d'énergie donc la zone
d'habitabilité va se rapprocher de
l'étoile et si elles sont plus larges
la zone d'habitabilité va être plus loin
de l'étoile et donc les astronomes ont
défini cette zone d'habitabilité qui est
représenté en bleu sur la diapositive et
c'est la zone dans laquelle on peut
essayer de retrouver des planètes
habitable comme la terre la sueur il
faut qu'elle ressemble à la terre
qu'elle soit tellurique donc elle
faisait un manteau et pas qu'elle soit
gazeuses comme jupiter
donc ça c'est ce que font les astronomes
à l'heure actuelle ils cherchent des
planètes du style de la terre dans les
zones habitables et y en a un grand
nombre et plus plus la technologie
avance plus on peut on observe ce genre
de planète on les appelle les
exoplanètes sont elles comme la terre
sont elles dans la zone d'habitabilité
c'est ce que les astronomes essaie de
déterminer en guise de conclusion je
voudrais simplement vous dire que le
système de le système solaire est
exceptionnel et notre terre est
exceptionnelle on peut dans notre propre
système solaire éventuellement ali
trouver la vie à l'intérieur des lunes
autour de jupiter et de saturne mais
certainement les astronomes une très
bonne idée d'aller chercher dans
d'autres systèmes solaires ou système
des toiles dans parmi les exoplanètes
essayer d'aller les observer j'espère
que je vous ai donné du rêve je vous
remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]